ااا اذا ينضم الينا مراسلنا من الاردن
عماد عضايله لنساله اكثر تفاصيل اكثر عن
هذه الحادثه
عماد هل تسمعني نعم نعم
قبل ساعه من الان نعم
العقيد عبد الرزاق الدلابيح وهو نائب شرطه
محافظه معان جنوب الاردن هذا العقيد تعرض
لاصابه بعيار مالك في منطقه الراس كان قد
كان يتعامل مع المحتجين في هذه المنطقه
المحتجون الذين بداوا بالاحتجاب منذ ايام
على ارتفاع اسعار المحروقات وكان هذا يعني
يسر اطلاق نار وكانت العيار الناري كانت
في منطقه الراس ثم اسعاره الى المستشفى
وتبارك الحياه هناك هذه همم يعني هذه
الاحتجاجات التي بدات منذ ثلاث ايام على
ارتفاع اسعار المحروقات بدات في مناطق
الجنوبيه
في منطقه المعان وفي منطقه وفي محافظه في
محافظه معان ومحافظه الكرك ومحافظه
الطفيله ايضا كان هناك بعض اعمال الشغب في
في امتياده المناطق كان الامن العام قد
سيطر عليها وهذه احدى الحالات التي كان
يتعامل معها الامن العام هناك من اطلق
النار همم على همم
العقيد الدلابيح هذا يعني هذه همم يعني
اللي اول مره تحدث في الاردن ان يكون
اطلاق نار على اتجاه القوات الامنيه وهذا
منعطف يعني يعتبره البعض خطير جدا ان يتم
اطلاق النار على ال ال ال ال ال ال ال
من اقدم على هذه على هذا العمل
بحسب يعني البيان وبحسب المعلومات التي
حصلنا عليها ان من اطلق النار هم يعني
مجهولون
كانوا ملاكمين ولا ولم نعلم بعد ان كان
الامن العام قد حدد يعني الذين قاموا بهذه
العمليه لكن الامن العام وفي البيان ايضا
يعني توعدت كل من يتوانى او يعني يريد
الخراب ل همم الاردن ولكل من يعني لحفظ
السلام لحفظ الامن الوطني وقال بالبيان
بحرف الواحد
كل من يحاول الاعتداء على الارواح
والممتلكات لذلك الامن العام يقول اننا
مستمرون ايضا في يعني وقت هذه الاحتجاجات
الغير مسؤوله هناك هذا الاحتجاج سبقه قبل
اسابيع تقريبا قبل 10 ايام
صدقه او كانت بدايه هذه الاحتجاجات هي
عباره عن اعتصام سلمي لي او اضراب سلمي لي
للشاحنات ومن ثم ال ال ال
وسائل النقل العام والايضا التكاسي وبعض
المركبات التي تعمل على التطبيقات همم
الذكيه هذه يعني هذه الاعتصامات التي
الذي قتل اليوم
والمنصب واسمه
العقيد هو العقيد عبد الرزاق عبد الحافظ
الدلابيح وهو نائب مدير شرطه محافظه معان
ويعني وهو رتبه يعني ليست يعني هو ضابط
بالتاكيد انه ضابط مخضرم بانه نائب يعني
محافظ مدير الشرطه وايه يعني محافظه معان
يعني في بعض الاحيان يكون هناك بعض
الخارجين عن القانون وبعض الموجودين ايضا
من المجتمع ومن همم
والديهم ايضا يعني ربما يعني همم قيود
امنيه سابقه لذلك يعني اليوم اثناء هذا او
هذه همم العمليه اثناء عمليه همم وقف هذه
الاحتجاجات هناك من استغلها هذا الضرب
واستغل همم الاحتجاجات قام باطلاق النار
همم
كما تحدثت لك يعني
البيان الامن العام قال انهم من المخربين
والخارجين عن القانون وهذا يعني هذا ما
تحدث فيه بيان الامن الامن العام ونحن
نقول ايضا وهناك معلومات ان ال ال ال
البعض يستغل هذه الاحتجاجات ويستغل
ال- ال- الاعتصامات بالتخريب وايضا يعني
اطلاق النار كما حدث اليوم اطلاق النار
على همم الامن العام وهي سابقه طبعا وتسمى
استغلالها من قبل الخارجين عن القانون
يعني لاداره الفوضى والاثاره ايضا الفتن
في المجتمع الاردني
بشكل عام يعني هناك خرجت اليوم او شهدت
بعض مناطق الاردن احتجاجات شعبيه رافقتها
اغلاقات ايضا لبعض الطرق
الفرعيه في بعض المدن وبعض المحافظات
الجنوبيه وحتى بعض المحافظات همم الشمال
يعني كان هناك احتجاجات وكان هناك حرق
لبعض الاطارات في الشوارع وفي ايضا اغلاق
لبعض هذه الطرق لكنها الامن العام همم كان
يعني سيطره على هذه الاحتجاجات كانت
الاحتجاجات او او يعني همم احتجاجات كانت
لشبان يقومون باغلاق الطرقات وكان الامن
العام وقام الامن العام بالسيطره على هذه
الاحتجاجات لكن في هذه المنطقه وفي
المنطقه الجنوبيه التي يعني في منطقه
تحديدا في منطقه الحسينيه وهي منطقه همم
تقع على الطريق الصحراوي الذي يربط ما بين
همم عمان وما بين او المحافظات الجنوبيه
التي المنطقه التي حصلت بها الحادثه هي
منطقه الحسينيه هذه المنطقه شهدت احتجاجات
ايضا وشاهدت اغلاق لبعض الطرق ربما كان
يعني
العقيد الدلابيح كان يعني يريد
يعني وقت هذه الاحتجاجات والقبض على بعض
الخارج خارجين على القانون لذلك يعني تم
استغلالها من قبل هؤلاء الاشخاص واقاموا
باطلاق النار الاوضاع عن الان في همم في
محافظات همم في المحافظات وحتى بالعاصمه
خرجت ايضا مسيره كانت حاشده في منطقه في
منطقه وسط البلد كانت يعني المطالبه
بتخفيض اسعار المحروقات لكن همم يعني
انتهت هذه وانتهت شبه انتهت هذه
الاحتجاجات في كافه منطقه في كافه مناطق
همم المملكه همم يعني ننتظر ايضا ان كان
هناك اي بيانات اخرى ان كان هناك اي طبعا
همم
شكرا على كل تلك المعلومات
سنبقى في هذا الموضوع في النشرات المقبله
معك لتوفينا بتفاصيل اضافيه عن الموضوع
شكرا جزيلا لك